[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
janvier 2023 la réforme des retraites
promesse de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
arrivant débat au Parlement une très
grande majorité des Français y est
opposé faire rarissime les syndicats à
l'unisson appellent à la grève
la suite c'est le gouvernement qui l'a
entre les mains en partie sur les 64 ans
et
les parlementaires je crois qu'il faut
que ce soit raisonnable et sinon il y
aura d'autres journées de mobilisation
quand on est élu on n'a pas un blanc
simple pendant 5 ans pour faire ce qu'on
veut
[Musique]
pour cette réforme le gouvernement a
pris une décision lourde de conséquences
il choisit non pas un projet de loi
classique mais un plfssr un projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale car les retraites impacteront
les comptes de la Sécu l'avantage pour
le gouvernement c'est que l'article 47-1
de la Constitution dont dépendent les
textes budgétaires entraîne une durée de
débat plus courte 50 jours en tout
commissions assemblée et Sénat compris à
la fin du délai prévu le gouvernement
pourrait légiférer par ordonnance et
donc enjamber le Parlement
ce choix de présenter une réforme si
importante dans un processus aussi
contraint va d'emblée crisper les
positions
bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
à l'Assemblée nationale les débats
s'ouvrent début février les députés de
gauche France insoumise en tête dépose
20 000 amendements la gauche s'emporte
la droite se divise et la discussion
s'enlise
laisser parler le ministre
mais pas dans un Nancy on n'est pas dans
une manip on est dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
il vous faudra répondre aux questions
que légitimement les parlementaires vous
posent monsieur le ministre donnez-nous
le nombre de personnes qui pourront
partir avec une retraite à 1200 euros
nous voulons savoir
tête
on va vous le répéter jusqu'à la fin de
la semaine retirez cette réforme c'est
l'heure de reculer retirez votre réforme
retirez vos amendements d'obstruction et
nous pourrons aller débattre vous avez
la responsabilité de ses choix
politiques vous êtes un imposteur et un
assassin
en neuf jours les députés n'auront
examinés que deux articles sur les vins
que contre la réforme et ils n'ont pas
débattu du fameux article 7 celui qui
décale l'âge de la retraite de 62 à 64
ans
la solutions que nos débats doivent
désormais prendre fin ce délai s'achève
ce soir les 20.500 amendements déposés
par la nuprette auront empêché notre
assemblée d'achever l'examen du texte le
gouvernement ne peut pas prolonger
l'examen du texte sans réduire le temps
que le Sénat doit avoir
l'Assemblée nationale n'ayant pas émis
de vote en première lecture sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi le
gouvernement on saisira le texte
modifié par les amendements votés par
votre assemblée mesdames et messieurs
les députés insoumis vous m'avez insulté
15 jours vous sortez mais vous m'avez
insulté personne n'a craqué personne n'a
craqué et nous sommes là devant vous
pour la réforme
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est dans cet état que le texte
arrive au Sénat fin février
ici on nous promet une autre ambiance
mais pas vraiment de suspense la droite
y est majoritaire et unique
contrairement à l’assemblée alliée avec
le Centre elle a toutes les clés en main
pour faire voter un texte sur mesure
et ça tombe bien la retraite à 64 ans
c'est leur idée depuis des années
c'est pas tout à fait notre réforme mais
elle y ressemble fortement ça fait
nombre d'années que nous disons que le
système de retraite par répartition est
déséquilibré qu'il faut prendre des
mesures de façon à pouvoir le pérenniser
et en conséquence le jour arrive ou ces
mesures doivent être prises
et la prévision d'un déficit à 13,5
milliards en 2030 nous oblige à avoir
cette obligation de soutenabilité
financière donc nous devons agir pour la
droite cette réforme est la seule option
pour sauver le régime par répartition
pour eux avec l'allongement de la durée
de la vie il est naturel de travailler
plus longtemps mais à ce stade il
considère aussi le projet du
gouvernement trop abrupt et veulent lui
apporter des aménagements
avec la gauche l'opposition est
verticale ici pas de France insoumise
pas de nupes la gauche se sont les
socialistes les communistes et les
écologistes les trois groupes
considèrent que reculer l'âge de la
retraite va générer plus de précarité
d'inégalités et des chômeurs plus
longtemps au chômage ils veulent
proposer des pistes de financement
alternative et comme à l'Assemblée
nationale empêché un vote final sur
cette loi dont ils ne veulent pas
pas échappé que nous étions minoritaire
au sein du Sénat mais nous serons une
opposition
déterminée nous battre contre cette
réforme qui traduit finalement
l'entêtement d'un gouvernement et aussi
l'endettement du président de la
République à faire passer en force
contre manifestement une très grande
majorité des Français une réforme que
nous qualifions d'injuste et oui elle
n'est pas juste
[Musique]
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que cette loi ne soit pas votée nous
sommes
absolument défavorables au recul de
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans donc notre
stratégie c'est de nombreux amendements
de telle sorte que nous puissions
aborder tous les sujets et amener le
gouvernement
que dans ces derniers retranchements
la gauche a déposé 4700 amendements qui
sont autant de propositions de
modification du texte
4700 c'est beaucoup même si on est loin
des 20 000 de l'Assemblée en 11 jours de
débat seulement tout l'enjeu sera de
maîtriser les horloges
[Musique]
le 2 mars c'est l'ouverture des débats
la prestigieuse salle des conférences du
Sénat est remplie de journalistes prêt à
scruter à la loupe ce moment important
pour la démocratie parlementaire
à mon micro il y aura pas leur rose jour
est
on prévoit plus de 70 heures de direct
la loi est hyper technique il va falloir
suivre
son visation on vous demande de par la
loi d'attendre l'âge légal de 64 ans
parce que vous avez compris que nous
étions chauds que nous travaillons
vraiment une très grande coordination
complémentarité politique avec les deux
groupes et que donc nous allons faire
notre travail de parlementaire et ça
c'est quand même une bonne chose pour
l'image de nos institutions
les deux camps vont-ils parvenir à
s'écouter c'est ce qu'on va voir allez
c'est parti pour 11 jours quelques nuits
ou Ken compris
du jour rappelle la discussion du projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 dont le Sénat
est saisir et il est demandé un rappel
au règlement de madame la présidente du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
madame assassin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues à l'orée du débat de la plus
grande importance qui engage l'avenir de
notre peuple je souhaite affirmer ici
quelques principes qui vont guider
l'action de notre groupe et formuler une
exigence nous exigeons avec 90% des
actifs les millions de personnes qui
manifestent et l'ensemble des syndicats
le retrait de ce projet de loi il est
donc
article 42 chapitre 14 du règlement
monsieur le débat doit avoir lieu et
notre groupe comme les autres groupes de
gauche utilisera tous les moyens
constitutionnels pour relayer ici les
préoccupations populaires je vais donner
la parole au ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion Monsieur
Olivier dussobe monsieur le ministre
nous y sommes nous y sommes à nouveau si
je puis dire et nous y sommes enfin
cette réforme des retraites j'y crois
profondément j'y crois parce qu'elle
sort d'abord notre système par
répartition d'un état structurellement
déficitaire cette réforme j'y crois
aussi parce qu'elle rend plus juste
notre système de retraite en répondant à
de très longs attentes des Françaises et
des Français et j'y crois enfin parce
que c'est tout simplement une promesse
tenue je sais qu'ici par de là les
divergences politiques on s'écoute je
sais qu'ici par de la les oppositions de
fond on débat je sais qu'ici par de là
les parcours de chacun on se respecte je
sais qu'ici il n'y a pas de ZAD il n'y a
que la République
et donc je serai tenté d'espérer
qu'après le vacarme et l'obstruction des
extrêmes s'ouvrent à cet instant le
temps de la sagesse et de la raison nous
aussi nous voulons un débat mais pour
faire un débat il faut être deux nous
avons donc des questions et nous
espérons obtenir quelques réponses par
exemple qui gagnera les 1200 euros tout
le monde comme vous l'avez fait croire
au début ou seulement 20 000 personnes
comme la démontrer le député Guedj à
l'Assemblée nationale en quoi un index
pour l'emploi des seniors sera-t-il plus
utile quand on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui de l'index sur l'égalité
salariale femme homme comment vous
croire quand vous dites la main sur le
cœur vouloir défendre la retraite par
répartition alors que le même casting
ministériel nous disait en 2019 qu'il
fallait absolument la capitalisation et
la retraite par point 64 ans on est ni
juste socialement
ni efficace financièrement et nous
sommes prêts déterminés bienvenue au
Sénat et bon débat
merci c'est vrai qu'habituellement au
groupe socialiste et apparenté nous
aimons débattre ce que nous allons faire
d'ailleurs donc nous appelons au débat
mais il s'avère que cette fois-ci le
débat est tronqué vous avez dit que le
débat était tronqué contre contenu dans
un nombre d'heures limitées plus de 100
heures mes chers collègues alors c'est
pas assez pour discuter de 4800
amendements et si vous voulez qu'on
discute effectivement jusqu'au bout
n'hésitez pas retirer ceux qui sont
redondants merci
pour l'instant ça se passe comment pour
l'instant on a l'impression qu'on parle
beaucoup mais qu'on agit peu ça vous
agréablement j'attends qu'on entre
vivement dans le débat le Parlement est
là pour cela
amendement après amendement la gauche
sénatoriale veut tenir le cap jusqu'au 7
mars pour aborder l'article 7 celui qui
décale l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans
le 7 mars sera aussi une date symbolique
les syndicats ont appelé ce jour-là la
plus grosse manifestation depuis le
début de la mobilisation mais avant cela
il y a d'autres sujets
présentés leur le texte ils sont dans la
rue ils préféreraient aller sûrement aux
urnes
l'article 1 de la réforme est un dossier
sensible il va s'agir de supprimer des
régimes spéciaux de retraite pour les
nouveaux entrants mis en place
historiquement pour reconnaître la
pénibilité de certains métiers les
régimes spéciaux permettent aux salariés
de partir avant l'âge légal 5 secteurs
sont visés dans cette loi dont la RATP
les industries électriques et gazières
et les clercs de nos terres la gauche
dépose 350 amendements
allez allez allez allez
on s'installe
voilà la journée va être longue
mettez-vous à l'aise
la séance est ouverte monsieur le
ministre vous êtes en forme je vous vois
souriant et dynamique c'est bien
amendement de Madame Cohen oui monsieur
le Président notre amendement est un
amendement de suppression exprime vous
vous en doutez notre désaccord face à la
suppression des régimes spéciaux à
contrario nous plaît donc pour leur
généralisation au régime général le
travail des cheminots des traminots des
gaziers électriciens et de tendons
d'ailleurs nous ne connaissons aucun
privilégié chez eux ni milliardaire ce
sont des hommes et des femmes qui chaque
jour assurent une mission de service
public dans des conditions difficiles
vous pourriez par exemple proposer des
mesures nouvelles sur une très forte
augmentation des salaires des
conducteurs de bus RATP etc non rien du
tout
on sent que l'avenir du pays dépend du
statut de retraite des clercs de notaire
il se trouve que la le régime de
retraite des clercs de notaire ne coûte
pas un centime à l'état alors
franchement d'habitude vous vous
souvenez les patrons et ben là les
patrons ils demandent le maintien du
système le scrutin est l'eau exprimé 341
pour 98 contre 243 ses amendements de
suppression ne sont pas adoptés
au fil des séances tous les amendements
de l'opposition sont systématiquement
rejetés
il n'est pas adopté 3025 même vote 3026
même vote 3027 même vote 3028
identiques la majorité sénatoriale
réussite à faire adopter l'article 1
dans la soirée mais sans confronter ses
arguments leur stratégie est d'avancer
le plus vite possible sur les bancs la
majorité écoute ne dis rien et ça
commence à se voir pour tout vous dire
nous défendrons tous nos amendements et
vous auriez honneur justement à
intervenir dans ce débat nous avons
attendu une seule prise de parole mais
intervenez c'est votre effort défendez
là justifiez là argumentez c'est ça le
Parlement c'est pas de se taire c'est
pas d'avoir un bas le bâillon Retailleau
sur la bouche
avec mes enfants à la maison je joue au
roi du silence à la maison ça fait du
bien mais dans l'hémicycle c'est moins
bien
d'abord le droit d'amendement est
constitutionnel et ici nous sommes là
pour parler et pour faire la loi et pour
la fabriquer il faut une confrontation
d'idées et nous vous le disons chacun
avait nos mots mais nous sommes prêts au
débat assez argumentés mais il faut que
en face aussi il y a une réaction sinon
on va passer 12 jours oui extrêmement
difficile pour les uns comme pour les
autres une reprochez de ne pas prendre
la parole pour défendre nos amendements
pour défendre l'article assumer d'être
dans une obstruction par rapport à vos
amendements quand on voit que sur la des
amendements de suppression alors que
vous avez l'habitude généralement de
grouper au sein du même groupe un
amendement de suppression vous faites 62
amendements de suppression pour un
article pardonnez-moi mais si c'est pas
de l'obstruction c'est quoi tout le
monde sait que vous avez négocié avec le
gouvernement pour que la réforme qui
sortira
de ceux de cette hémicycle si elle est
votée soit tout à fait conforme à ce que
vous voulez alors ma question est simple
qu'attendez-vous de nous
que nous ne jouions pas notre rôle
d'opposant que nous fermions
définitivement notre bouche au prétexte
que nous sommes minoritaires et que vous
avez déjà tout négocié c'est ça votre
conception du débat républicain
nous pourrions effectivement
plus participer mais ce serait réduit le
temps que l'on veut porter à d'autres
questions donc c'est toujours le dilemme
est-ce qu'on intervient après chaque
intervention après chaque amendement
alors que ce sont des amendements de
suppression la plupart du temps donc on
ne peut intervenir qu'une seule fois je
pose la question est-ce que on doit
participer finalement à l'encombrement à
l'obstruction qui est lancée par
l'opposition
[Musique]
après quatre jours de discussion le ton
monte la droite voudrait introduire une
réflexion autour d'une part de
capitalisation dans le calcul des
retraites une partie serait alors prise
en charge par des fonds privés
je pense qu'on pourrait étudier un
système d'une fusée à trois étages le
premier étage c'est le socle c'est la
répartition c'est le lien
intergénérationnel le second étage le
deuxième étage c'est les complémentaires
gérés par les partenaires sociaux et
l'autre étage de la fusée ce serait un
étage par capitalisation alors je ne
connais pas les compétences de Bruno
retaillod en astronomie et en fusée mais
donc je suis allé voir savoir comment
marche les étages d'une fusée chaque
étage est doté de son ou de ses propres
moteurs et lorsque le carburant est vide
l'étage et largué dans l'espace on place
donc au sommet de la fusée ce que l'on
veut emporter dans l'espace
faire de la capitalisation le dernier
étage de la fusée c'est donc précisément
faire de la répartition le premier étage
à abandonner donc ne soyons pas dupe
vous avez pris vous même la meilleure
métaphore que vous auriez pu prendre
j'aurais aimé qu'on la trouve nous-mêmes
mais je vous remercie de l'avoir fait
est-ce que vous pensez véritablement que
les caissières les aident à domicile les
petits smicards
non mais vous rigolez pas à sang dans la
capitalisation vous savez où ils sont
actuellement ils se font la queue au
Resto du Coeur ils sont au Secours
populaire ils n'arrivent plus à payer
leur électricité leur gaz ils pensent
tous les jours à se nourrir mais oui
monsieur c'est ça la réalité de l'avion
que toi peut-être pas les mêmes en tous
les cas vous irez dire à tous ces gens
qu'il faut qu'ils capitalise parce que
finalement vous voulez leur enlever le
régime par répartition
cet amendement sera adopté mais à une
plus courte majorité et contre la vie du
gouvernement
[Musique]
arrive maintenant un accent important à
prendre en compte l'emploi des seniors
car s'il faut partir à la retraite plus
tard encore faut-il trouver du travail
ou le garder à partir d'un certain âge
il nous a semblé important de bâtir dès
à présent bien que ce soit une loi
retraite une politique vis-à-vis de
l'emploi des seniors qu'on pourrait
appeler monsieur le ministre
un seigneur une solution
l'intention le texte contient deux
mesures la première qui émane du
gouvernement est un index senior écrit
un outil de mesure de l'implication des
entreprises pour l'emploi des seniors
les entreprises devront publier le taux
d'emploi de leur salarié les plus âgés
mais cette mesure ne coûte pas d'argent
ni n'en rapporte c'est ce qu'on appelle
un cavalier social elle n'a a priori
rien à faire dans une loi de finances
nous on désespère pas du tout de
l'emploi des seniors nous pensons que
les seniors peuvent être très utiles
dans les années à venir dans
l'entreprise on nous pensons aussi que
cette index senior et cette question de
l'emploi des seniors c'est une question
qui concerne le paritarisme on désespère
pas non plus à la différence de ce qu'on
entend de la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises sociales et sociétales des
entreprises et des entrepreneurs et
c'est tout le sens de cette index senior
je vous remercie qu'est-ce que c'est
cette index au fond on a déjà l'exemple
avec l'index sur les inégalités
salariales et le résultat c'est quoi
c'est que ça ne sert absolument à rien
hein parce que il y a pas de sanction
deux parce que c'est tellement mal fait
que même les indicateurs sont faux on a
en France des entreprises où il y a des
inégalités salariales énormes et qui ont
des notes magnifiques
100% 90% etc donc c'est comme essayer de
soigner la fièvre avec un thermomètre
cassé
là en l'occurrence qu'on a ne sert
absolument à rien et je ne comprends pas
qu'on soit même en train d'en discuter
le rapporteur
ta maman porte sur les seniors au
chômage 2 milliards consacrés par
lunédique pour les chômeurs de plus de
60 ans ça doit quelque part nous
interpeller donc ce qui veut dire que
les outils actuels d'emploi des seniors
ne sont pas suffisants c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons sur proposition
de longues de partenaires sociaux
proposés ce CDI senior le CDI Seigneur
la deuxième idée est un CDI senior une
sorte de contrat spécial pour les plus
de 60 ans avec un petit allègement de
charge pour les entreprises la droite
tient à cette mesure quelle considère
plus sociale elle en a même fait une
condition de son soutien à la réforme
mais le gouvernement n'y est pas
favorable
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
moi je suis toujours assez sceptique sur
des propositions d'allègement de
cotisations ciblées sur un âge donné
pour une bonne raison à mon avis c'est
que le risque c'est qu'il y a des effets
de seuil si vous dites il y a un
allègement de cotisation pour
l'employeur à partir de 60 ans qu'est-ce
qui va se passer pour les gens qui ont
58 59 ans qui se présentent dans une
entreprise pour être recrutée c'est la
première chose sur la deuxième chose
c'est un amendement qui coûte
effectivement
une certaine somme moi je ne comprends
pas pourquoi on est toujours obligé de
faire des cadeaux aux entreprises
pour que elle recrute des gens soit
c'est des jeunes soit c'est des seniors
soit c'est finalement et alors les
entreprises recrutent qui des gens qui
ont entre 25 et 55 ans et puis après
avant ça va pas après ça va plus moi
j'aurais préféré que l'on demande juste
aux entreprises en fonction de certains
critères de recruter ou de maintenir un
emploi des seniors pour qu'elle puisse
garder les diverses exonérations
auxquelles elles ont déjà droit
le CDI senior est adopté l'index senior
est également mais sans obligation de
résultats pour les entreprises malgré
les tentatives de l'opposition de rendre
la mesure plus contraignante il est
adopté
[Musique]
il reste alors où l'on se parle de 1917
amendements à examiner d'ici à dimanche
toute la question maintenant et de
savoir quand est-ce que sera examiné
l'article 7 vous savez celui sur le
décalage de l'âge de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans l'article 7 la
gauche aimerait l'examiner ce serait
sans doute d'après nos dernières
informations dans la soirée de demain
[Musique]
ça y est on y est c'est le 7 mars cet
après-midi ce sera le début de l'article
7 mais pour le moment c'est l'heure de
la manif
un combat mais un combat motivant
d'abord parce qu'on se sent appui au
mouvement social comme on dit on lâche
rien les syndicats ont appelé à mettre
la France à l'arrêt ce jour-là et les
sénateurs de gauche vont prendre un
petit bain pour tester la température de
l'opinion
[Musique]
c'est une bataille politique ces deux
projets de société qui s'affrontent donc
nous on a des arguments on est utile on
est déterminé on va aller jusqu'au bout
on voulait débattre de l'article 7 on va
le commencer là après la manifestation
et puis on va faire ce que vous voulez
que ça commence juste
et même en étant minoritaire et
d'opposition on y est arrivé parce que
si on les écoutait
la droite il voulait plier le truc en
trois jours donc on a tenu bon on
voulait en arriver là on y est cette
mars 7e article donc la bataille la
bataille recommande maintenant c'est une
nouvelle bataille qui s'annonce la
journée va être longue et ils ne savent
pas encore à quel point
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a fait des propositions de
financement d'amélioration des retraites
on a fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
améliorer le système de retraite tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ni la majorité
sénatoriale ni le gouvernement ne
veulent de nos propositions mais en
dernière analyse notre fonction notre
but c'est d'empêcher que cette loi soit
adoptée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malheureusement faut pas y rester
puisque on doit tout être tous être en
séance dans une demi-heure maintenant là
il y a l'article 6 qui arrive alors du
jour et puis vers 17h 17h30 18h on verra
bien l'article 7 et là ça va être la
grosse grosse bataille puisque pour nous
cette merde des réformes c'est une très
mauvaise mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord une réforme des retraites c'est
toujours difficile à 19h comme prévu
commence l'examen de l'article 7 c'est
le pilier de la réforme et là la gauche
ne veut rien laisser passer ils ont
déposé 1200 amendements rien que sur cet
article
la parole est à monsieur le rapporteur
nous on n'est pas la parole même la
présidente n'est pas la parole pour
l'instant non même la Présidente je lui
ai donné la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur
merci Madame Liliane assassy bon effet
tribune étant passé on va revenir à la
sérénité des débats
[Applaudissements]
c'est le Ministre ça fait quatre ans
qu'on vous propose ce type
d'architecture de réforme c'est pas
parce que nous sommes des tétus c'est
parce que nous pensons que c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire en sorte de
pouvoir équilibrer notre système de
retraite si nous voulons le confier à
nos enfants et effectivement on sait que
nous avons un système fondé sur deux
piliers à la fois la durée de cotisation
et un autre pilier un âge légal et nous
avons pensé qu'il était important de
trouver un équilibre entre les deux nous
voyons moi sur dix nous voici donc à
arriver au moment tant attendu à
l'article le plus important pour le
quotidien des Français celui sur le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans le noyau de
cette réforme injuste qui fait peser
tous les efforts sous les épaules des
travailleuses et les travailleurs même
sans parler vous avez réussi à empirer
le texte avec le contrat dernier
embauche ou en introduisant une part de
capitalisation vous me faites penser au
biais de tout chercheur scientifique
qui s'appelle l'apologue dit du
lampadaire quelqu'un a perdu ses clés et
ne cherche qu'autour d'un lampadaire on
lui dit mais tu as pu les perdre
ailleurs quand même pourquoi tu cherches
seulement autour de du lampadaire il dit
mais c'est le seul endroit où il y a de
la lumière alors vous c'est le
lampadaire le lampadaire du paramètre
âge légal de la retraite que vous avez
allumé nous on fait que de vous dire
allumer d'autres d'autres lampadaires
allumer même toute la place le déficit
de la Sécu il est peut-être comblable un
petit peu ailleurs et donc allumer le
lampadaire de la contribution des
revenus financiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les heures passent et la majorité
commencent à manifester son impatience
[Musique]
depuis cinq jours cinq nuits nous sommes
patients la gauche multiplie et
centaines et des centaines d'amendements
tous identiques souvent nous venions
d'avoir successivement 77 amendements de
suppressions et on allait avoir tout
autant finalement d'explication de texte
sur les mêmes amendes donc moi je
considère que l'obstruction de c'est la
négation de enfin dans les couloirs on
sent que quelque chose va se passer il
se murmure que la présidence du Sénat
pourrait actionner des armes de
procédure dans le règlement du Sénat
pour accélérer les débats mais lesquels
pour l'instant on ne sait pas
une fois
deux minutes
réponse de la Commission
[Applaudissements]
va pas être naïf président du Sénat
contrairement à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a des procédures
qu'il peut dégainer grâce au Règlement
du Sénat et le gouvernement a le petit
frère du 49-3 qu'il peut dégainer donc
tout ça on le sait donc on va s'adapter
il reste plus de 1000 amendements à
examiner sur l'article 7 la gauche
bataille pied à pied sur chaque détail
le gouvernement et la droite ne veulent
rien négocier vous êtes obsédé par une
seule idée les 64 ans à part ça rien ne
vous intéresse aucune piste alternative
de trouve grâce à vos yeux et bien je le
répète face au pays qui est unanimement
mobilisé c'est un coup de force nous
l'assumons parce que cette borne d'âge
permettra non seulement de sauver la
réforme et le régime par répartition et
même si la réforme est provisoirement
impopulaire nous en avons connu d'autres
mais quand on est et quand on fait de la
politique on assume ce qui est bon pour
le pays et cette réforme à terme elle ne
sera pas abrogée pas plus que vous
n'aviez abrogé la précédente
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voter cet article 7 ah oui
pourquoi pas je vais le voter oui
vous allez y arriver que vous avez une
beauté j'espère bien oui j'espère bien
parce que sinon tout ça pour ça on se
poserait tous la question parce que ça
doit être des sels
avec nous non moi j'ai sentiments que
vous avez envie de savoir qui est-ce qui
va se passer Elisabeth Doisneau qui a un
rôle clé dans le déroulé du débat les
s'entendre aux journalistes que
l'article 7 pourrait être voté le
lendemain matin et il y a une assassin
n'en a pas perdu une miette elle sait
qu'avec tous les amendements qui restent
à examiner ça ne pourra pas rentrer en
une nuit elle vient de comprendre que
l'offensive va commencer on vous a
entendu hyper attentive à ce qu'elle
disait
faites le calcul enfin c'est
mathématiques donc il va bien se passer
quelque chose si Madame ouanneau nous
dit que demain matin à l'aube l'article
7 est plié bah non c'est pas possible
normalement c'est pas possible donc si
c'est pas possible si pour être pour
être possible il faut des gainer des
procédures c'est tout simple
par exemple là vous êtes en train de
d'imaginer tous les scénarios
j'en sais rien à minuit 58 premiers
action le président Retailleau demande
l'application de l'article 38 du
Règlement qui limite les prises de
parole sur un amendement
c'est un rappel aux règlements monsieur
le Président à partir c'est sur la base
de l'article 38 77 amendements de
suppression
tout s'identique monsieur le Président
je demande cette application
je ne comprends pas l'usage de cet
article l'usage de cet article 38 je
pense que vous avez encore la
possibilité de le retirer c'est un
moment grave c'est un moment important
je j'espère que vous que vous que vous
rendez compte de la responsabilité que
vous avez franchement
je vous ai écouté depuis longtemps j'ai
écouté sur tous ces banques comme tous
mes collègues vous avez utilisé les
ressources du règlement pour faire
entendre votre opposition nous l'avons
écouté avec beaucoup de patience en
étant très conciliant vous vouliez qu'on
arrive à l'article 7 le 7 ça a été fait
et nous nous utilisons maintenant le
règlement pour faire entendre aussi une
autre voie et donc à partir de
maintenant et ben
comme on dit dans les campagnes les
mouches ont changé d'âne
il appartient au président de séance
d'appliquer ces limitations du temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté de sincérité du
débat parlementaire et je rappelle que
nous avons eu sur cet article on l'état
124 interventions je considère que les
exigences de clarté et de sincérité ont
été respectés par l'importance de ces
intervalles
[Applaudissements]
très en colère madame
c'est quoi la stratégie de
la politique ici
c'est sûr c'est moins long que les
séparer tout le monde
est-ce que vous répondez à la gauche qui
se sent bâillonnée par l'utilisation de
cet article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui
est d'ailleurs une première c'est la
première fois depuis que l'on intègre
cette mesure dans règlement du Sénat en
2015 que l'on l'utilise en séance moi je
respecte la philibusterie parlementaire
je sais qu'elle existe mais il y a un
moment donné il faut dire STOP parce que
c'est de la crédibilité du Parlement des
parlementaires et du Sénat parce qu'on
est regardé
si on les avait pas
bien on a une majorité sénatoriale et un
gouvernement totalement allié qui a
décidé de passer en force cette nuit
donc nous ferons tous cette nuit pour
s'empêcher pour empêcher ce coup de
force
il est 2h du matin et la bataille n'est
pas finie en coulisse la gauche se
prépare à la phase 2 qui ne saurait
tarder
une suspension de séance le rapporteur
revient avec une véritable bombe à
amendement au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales il propose une
réécriture de l'article 7
et nous avons réécrit l'article
[Musique]
pour une c'est un tour de passe-passe
rare ici le sens de l'article 7 ne
change pas mais ce n'est quand même plus
le même et tous les amendements qui
étaient reliés tombent mécaniquement
plus de 1100 amendements
qui se répartissent
comme nous nous y attendions également
voilà la réécriture de cette article 7
nous avons bien évidemment parce que
nous sommes courageux monsieur Lemoine
qui est parti
nous avons bien évidemment travaillé des
sous amendements et donc je vous remets
je remets au service de la séance les
sous amendements que mon groupe a vient
dépose pour
l'examen de cette réécriture de
l'article 7 vous allez pouvoir nous
remettre les sous amendements
et ce qui va m'amener madame la
Présidente à ce que la Commission se
remette au travail pour un certain temps
pour un certain temps monsieur le
Président donc je demande en effet une
suspension de séance pour réunir la
commission pour examiner les quelques on
parle de 3000
trop bien
vous verrez le chiffre d'arrivant ça se
pèse
la séance est suspendue trois quarts
d'heure pour que la Commission examine
la recevabilité de ces milliers de
nouveaux sous amendements
à deux heures 45 la séance reprend
la commission déclare y recevable les
sous amendements qui ne se rapportent
pas au texte et qui aurait pour effet de
contredire le sens des amendements de
l'amendement auquel il s'applique
[Musique]
si
c'est très clair
s'il vous plaît ils sont donc
irrecevables restent un amendement
recevable que celui du sénateur Artano
sur lequel leur apportera
donc en application de l'article 44 bis
alinéa neuf de notre règlement lire
recevabilité est admise
[Musique]
je suspends 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
ils ont dit que c'était pas recevable
parce que beaucoup d'entre eux ils ont
marre considérés qui ne se rattachait
pas directement à des phrases du texte
c'est son exactement les mêmes qui ont
été traités par la commission avant et
qui n'a jamais dit qu'ils étaient
recevables pour cette raison
laissez parler la Présidente j'ai dit
quelque chose qui vous fait rire non
vous me dites
la commission des affaires sociales a
pris la décision de rejeter tous les
sous amendements que nous avons déposé
et les a examinés à une vitesse je dois
dire et Claire donc j'ai une question
moi cela veut simplement dire que le
Sénat ne veut pas débattre de l'article
7 qui est pourtant
le cœur du texte et le sujet le sujet
d'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite qui préoccupe des millions de
nos concitoyens et de nos concitoyens et
je veux vous le dis aussi crûment que ça
nous refusons de participer à cette
entomine et nous quittons l'hémicycle ce
soir et nous reviendrons demain
[Musique]
entre vous avec le gouvernement donc là
je pense qu'on avait donné une bonne
image et que là on donne une image vous
donner une image désastreuse donc on va
[Applaudissements]
va repartir cette nuit et on reviendra
demain et j'espère qu'on pourra revenir
dans des conditions un peu plus sereine
pour pouvoir débattre et travailler
sereine il reste 75 amendements sur cet
article donc nous vous donnerons
rendez-vous pour le débat de fond sur
ces articles
et la sagesse et la réponse du Sénat
j'allais dire amendement éclair aux
amendement est clair et je souhaite que
nous ayons un débat mais que nos
caricaturions pas l'attitude de notre
tout seul
donc sur cette brouille manifeste que
nous nous séparons la gauche et la
droite qui est bien sont verticalement
opposés sur ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est un endroit de la Chambre
le lendemain les sénateurs reprennent
les débats mais tout le monde est groggy
la suite ne fait plus de mystère
l'article 7 sera voté en fin de journée
après plusieurs nouveaux recours au
Règlement
la suite du texte va assez vite une
mesure est adoptée et à l'unanimité une
surcote de 5% pour les maires de famille
les plus touchés par la réforme le Sénat
a adopté
ils en viennent aussi au dispositif
carrière longue pour lesquelles il faut
bien le dire personne ou presque ne
comprend le projet du gouvernement
cet article 8 est très important pour
notre groupe des Républicains monsieur
le ministre s'il vous plaît j'aurais
vraiment besoin avec les quelques vins
sénateurs qui ont signé mon amendement
sur la question des 43 ans d'explication
précise les carrières longues à certains
nombres d'entre nous n'y comprennent
rien nous avons voté les 64 ans il y a
la question des 43 ans pour équilibrer
les choses nous souhaiterions que ces 43
ans soit une limite maximum de
cotisations on a 43 ans on s'en va vous
avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur l'idée
que finalement nous pourrions garantir
que les 43 années de cotisation serait
une forme de plafond
et et que ça sera un plafond auquel
au-delà duquel on ne demandera à
personne d'aller je ne peux qu'être en
opposition avec cette proposition car
les principes même de construction de
notre système de retraite depuis qu'il
existe sont de cumuler deux conditions
pour le départ l'âge d'ouverture des
droits et une durée de cotisation sauf
que la durée de cotisation dans le
système tel qu'il est pensé n'a toujours
a toujours été vu comme un plancher
jamais comme un plafond
l'article est adopté mais dans un flou
persistant
le vendredi il reste encore trois jours
de débat mais face à la date butoir du
12 mars à minuit qui commence à
approcher sérieusement le gouvernement
abat sa dernière carte
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement demande à votre assemblée
de se prononcer par un vote unique sur
l'ensemble du texte
il dégaine l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution le vote bloqué une sorte de
49-3 pour le Sénat le gouvernement
choisi 70 amendements presque aucun de
gauche et ce seront les seuls à être
examinés jusqu'à la fin tous les autres
sont écartés
c'est une aliénation du Parlement c'est
tout simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien Sénat
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement voilà où on en est
[Applaudissements]
quand j'entends coup d'État quand
j'entends je ne sais quoi nous essayons
nous essayons de débattre ça n'a pas été
possible vous portez la responsabilité
vous portez la responsabilité du fait
qu'aujourd'hui le débat parlementaire
doivent céder le pas malheureusement à
une méthode plus autoritaire je le
regrette parce que je le regrette et je
le comprends je le regrette parce que
c'est jamais très agréable de dire qu'un
débat parlementaire se fait sans
véritable vote par amendement sans vote
des articles etc et seulement un vote à
l'extrême fin je le comprends parce que
bon ça fait 8 jours qu'on était dans une
situation de blocage d'obstruction par
des explications de vote un amplifié des
rappels règlements la multiplication est
sous amendement donc tout était fait
pour que au final le Sénat de votre pas
sur le texte de loi merci à vous
samedi 11 mars c'est l'avant-dernier
jour de discussion depuis le
déclenchement du vote bloqué
l'accélération est telle que la gauche
sait qu'elle ne parviendra plus à
empêcher un vote final
cette journée monsieur les ministres
mesdames messieurs restera une journée
noire pour tous les salariés de ce pays
nous savons que vous voterez le recul de
l'âge de la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
parce que nous savons chers collègues
que vous avez négocié avec le
gouvernement pour voir aboutir ce que
vous attendez depuis si longtemps
parce que nous savons messieurs les
ministres que le gouvernement s'est
soumis
afin de s'assurer le vote majoritaire du
Sénat dont vous avez impérativement
besoin pour apporter un minimum de
légitimité à votre texte
nous avons voulu agir et cette réforme
nous l'avons voulu monsieur le ministre
messieurs les ministres mais Monsieur le
Ministre du soft tout particulièrement
je voudrais m'adresser à vous
vous irez porter ce message au président
de la République c'est très fort nous
allons la voter mais nous ne doit-on pas
pour lui cette réforme nous la votons
parce que c'est notre réforme c'est ici
qu'elle est née nous la voterons parce
que nous l'avons modifié c'est notre
texte que nous allons voter
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
résultat du scrutin votant 344 exprimé
307 pour
195 contre 112 le Sénat à adopté la loi
sur la réforme des retraites est adoptée
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche avec
un jour d'avant
[Musique]
et j'accueille sur ce plateau le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher
bonsoir président bien sûr c'est une
double victoire d'abord la victoire
parce que pour nous le régime de
retraite par répartition il est
fondamental qu'on puisse le préserver
c'est ce que nous faisons ce soir nous
avons enrichi considérablement cette
réforme qui est née imposséna puisque le
gouvernement avait repris des
amendements convoité tous les ans depuis
4 ans et l'autre victoire c'est la
victoire du Sénat parce que nous avons
pu voter
c'est un débat sociétal d'une importance
quand même majeure on voit bien ça
touche les Français
je regrette je regrette quand même que
il y a eu finalement le débat qui a été
contrarié par des positions des postures
qui n'ont rien amené de positif me
semble-t-il parce que il y a des vrais
sujets de fond est-ce qu'on était
vraiment dans un débat de droit de
gauche dans ces fondamentaux j'allais
dire oh je pense qu'on a retrouvé par
moments des des affrontements droits de
gauche des visions de la valeur travail
différente ou certains pensent que le
travail c'est ça conduit à l'usure
à la pénibilité oui parfois mais
d'autres que pensent que à travers le
travail on peut aussi se retrouver c'est
pour ça que c'est des débats peuvent
être intéressants et que j'ai vraiment
regretté qu'il soit pénalisé par des
postures plus politiciennes que autre
chose c'est une défaite c'est toujours
une défaite quand on a un vote qui ne va
pas dans le sens que que l'on aurait
souhaité maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ce vote
qu'est-ce qui se passera après moi c'est
ça qui m'inquiète en tout cas c'est ça
qui m'inquiète parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui et ce soir rien n'est résolu
c'en est fini pour l'examen au Sénat
[Musique]
l'étape suivante c'est la commission
mixte paritaire c'est un huis clos entre
7 députés et sept sénateurs seulement
qui doivent se mettre d'accord sur un
texte commun les représentants de gauche
sont minoritaires face au macronistes et
aux républicains
à droite ça débat surtout de savoir où
commence et où finit une carrière
l'autre
après une journée passablement houleuse
un texte commun est adopté
le texte doit ensuite revenir dans les
deux chambres pour un vote finale au
Sénat sans surprise il est adopté je
vous invite mes chers collègues à voter
cette réforme
il faut ensuite repasser au vote à
l'Assemblée nationale toute la matinée
le gouvernement compte ses alliés chez
les républicains il compte et recompte
mais le contenu est pas
la séance est ouverte et elle est
également immédiatement suspendue
puisque pour le moment je n'ai le
gouvernement n'est pas représenté aux
bandes donc je suspends la séance
[Applaudissements]
8 minutes plus tard la séance est
ouverte cette fois la première ministre
s'avance à la tribune pour annoncer ce
que tout le monde redoutait ce sera le
49-3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
demandez à chacun des parlementaires qui
brandit une pancarte de bien vouloir
cesser immédiatement cela est contraire
à notre règlement
et la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés
aujourd'hui sur le texte du Parlement
l'incertitude plane à quelques doigts
près on ne peut pas prendre le risque de
voir 175 heures de débat parlementaire
s'effondrer on ne peut pas prendre le
risque de voir le compromis bâti par les
deux assemblées écartés on ne peut pas
faire de Paris sur l'avenir de nos
retraites cette réforme est nécessaire
aussi sur le fondement de l'article de
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 modifier par
l'amendement de coordination
communiquée à l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
le 49-3 met fin au processus
parlementaire les 102 heures de débat au
Sénat étaient censés convaincre les
députés républicains récalcitrants a
voté ce texte une loi votée par les deux
Chambres aurait été dès le gouvernement
à donner une légitimité parlementaire à
cette loi tant décrié ça n'aura donc pas
fonctionné
[Musique]